[Music]
on this saturday night rising tensions
across the country
as the so-called freedom rally parties
near parliament hill
protests and counter-protests spread to
other canadian cities
a brutal storm cuts power to thousands
in the maritimes as millions of
americans try to dig out from it team
canada on a tear a silver a bronze and a
hockey team that seems unbeatable in
beijing and the pioneering canadian
surgeon who's taking organ transplants
we built in a ballistic parachute to a
whole new level
national reporting tonight
colleen christie
[Music]
thousands of canadians have taken to the
streets across the country to protest
against pandemic restrictions
demonstrators have descended on major
cities in several provinces to show
solidarity with the so-called freedom
protest in ottawa
good evening thanks for joining us it
has been exactly a week since the
freedom convoy rolled into our nation's
capital and as mike trolley explains in
our top story tonight they're vowing to
stay for the long haul
this was a potentially volatile mix
protesters and counter protesters
separated by a thin line of ottawa
police who at times had to forcefully
keep the two groups apart
a week into the trucker-led occupation
of the nation's capital hayden avery
said he's had enough if anyone goes
outside you're basically looking at
getting slurs yelled at you you're you
know people threatening to you know take
your mask off or else
a stone's throw away what's dubbed as
the freedom convoy gathering was in full
swing
with impromptu dance parties and a
concert in the shadow of parliament hill
while protesters with megaphones
screaming about freedom were drowned out
by truck horns
there is no discussion
[Music]
lie here lie only the steadfast belief
they're fighting for the future of the
country and the mandates give give the
people of canada choice in the matter
a choice in the matter to wear the mask
to get the vaccine we shouldn't be
penalized for something
so
unbelievably inhumane as much as
residents were hopeful this protest
would end soon they have to be dismayed
at what they're seeing now
saunas ice huts and other semi-permanent
structures to cook food the message
they're in it for the long haul
ottawa police responded by blocking key
roads that's a public safety issue
citing safety is the reason for turning
away a horse-drawn wagon filled with
diesel fuel we're not letting vehicles
pass this checkpoint organizers also had
to scramble to come up with an
alternative fundraising platform to
gofundme which took down the convoy's
campaign citing violations of its terms
of service promising to refund roughly 9
million dollars in donations supporters
are now flocking to a christian
fundraising site that has been popular
in the past with right-wing extremist
groups donations topped a million
dollars by midday we got this we got
this guys
we're gonna wake up this world even more
that won't make ottawa residents happy
but protesters argue that's the price to
pay for freedom mike delay global news
ottawa
one of the largest solidarity protests
taking place today is in downtown
toronto more than 2 000 people have
gathered at queen's park which is home
to ontario's legislative building and
not far from some of the busiest
hospitals in the country global's allen
carter has been monitoring the situation
today and joins us now alan
colleen despite extensive road closures
in the city of toronto the convoy made
its way into the city loudly blocking a
major intersection
[Applause]
the blaring sound of protest in toronto
as truckers moved their rigs to block
downtown roads
prevented by police from getting close
to the provincial legislature protesters
gathered nearby provoking angry
reactions of their own
bigots
the ontario trucking association says
strongly disapproves of this
demonstration the message here now
familiar condemnation of politicians
and of the media
many also angered at how they've been
portrayed the disrespect that we're
shown by our leadership has to end we're
not yahoos protesters didn't block
health care workers and patients from
nearby hospitals but this emergency room
doctor says there's still been an impact
the fact that these roads are blocked
access has already been impeded okay so
the damage is done this nurse says she
joined the protest after refusing a
second dose of the vaccine following an
adverse reaction to the first i'm an
11 year nurse i've worked palliative
i've worked merged i've worked
multi-organ transplant units and i've
just been discarded as if i'm not worth
anything
wrapped in the flag sometimes quite
literally demonstrators believe the
volume of their protest must be heard by
those in power
[Applause]
toronto police report at least one
arrest as part of this demonstration a
22 year old man arrested for assault
with a weapon
colleen
thanks alan
a large crowd gathered outside quebec's
national assembly today following
quieter protests during the week
of course i meant
there's no democracy in there
organizers asked the group to remain
peaceful and respect orders from police
40 tickets were handed out on friday
mostly for highway safety code
infractions this is the third day of
protests in quebec's capital
a convoy that began in langley bc this
morning headed for downtown vancouver
was met with counter protesters several
dozen people laid in the street blocking
the protesters from continuing the road
eventually reopened and while the convoy
split in multiple directions hundreds of
trucks and cars ended up in the downtown
core
four people were injured in a hit and
run last night in front of the manitoba
legislature where demonstrators were
camped out the victims were all
protesters but police don't believe this
incident is related to the demonstration
based on the suspect's comments at the
scene although they wouldn't elaborate
this was not someone who was compliant
and the comments
were blurted out but as i i will repeat
it it looks like the
actions were not
really as a result of the mandates
a 41 year old from headingley manitoba
remains in custody he's expected to be
charged with a slew of offenses
including four counts of assault with a
weapon
under the shadow of those convoy
protests in ottawa the federal
conservatives ousted leader aaron
o'toole this week following a decisive
vote spurred by a caucus revolt and
right now the race is on for a new
leader to unify the caucus and determine
exactly where on the political spectrum
conservatives want to sit our ottawa
bureau chief mercedes stephenson joins
us now with the latest
mercedes well certainly a big question
for conservatives is who will lead the
party in what direction will it go in
and one of the names who keeps bubbling
up to the top is pierre pauliaf he is an
ottawa area mp he was also in stephen
harper's cabinet he's a lifelong
politician and he's pretty conservative
he has taken the side of the convoy here
in ottawa and supported it very publicly
he also has posted numerous videos
attacking the liberals in highly
partisan ways and he is seen to be the
front runner if he decides to run which
tells you the direction the party is
likely to go to this week on the west
block i had an exclusive interview with
john baird he was stephen harper's
minister of foreign affairs he's a close
friend and confidant of pierre polyes
and let me tell you in that interview it
certainly sounds like we have an
imminent announcement coming from pierre
polyeff that he will run take a listen
to why john baird says pierre pauliev is
the right man to lead the conservative
party next
i think he has the brains and more
important i think he's got the backbone
he's got extensive experience in
government i think he can bring the
conservative movement together he can
galvanize people but also i think uh he
can has proven that he can break through
and speak to canadians
and that'll be the big question can
someone who has been so polarizing in
fact break through and speak to
canadians in areas like the 905. mr
baird says he thinks that he can do that
so we will have to see if pierre poliev
announces but i doubt that someone like
john baird is out pumping him up if
there wasn't something in the cards
pretty quickly back to you good point
all right mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thanks mercedes and of course you can
watch the full interview with former
foreign affairs minister john baird
tomorrow on the west block right here on
global canada's non-lethal military aid
has arrived in ukraine to help bolster
the country's defenses against a
possible russian incursion
the equipment includes armored vests and
night vision goggles in a tweet defense
minister anita anand confirmed the aid
departed canadian forces-based trenton
thursday night saying the donation will
help security forces defend ukraine's
sovereignty territorial integrity and
independence that's the first wave of
u.s reinforcements touching down in
poland as russia flexes its military
might along ukraine's border its troops
landed this morning at an air force base
in poland's southeast near its border
with ukraine on wednesday u.s president
joe biden ordered 2 000 u.s based
personnel to be deployed to poland and
germany and shifted a thousand soldiers
from germany to romania to strengthen
nato's eastern flank
russia is stoking fears even further
after sending two long-range
nuclear-capable bombers on patrol over
the air space of ally belarus russia's
defense ministry said the bombers
practiced interacting with the
belarusian air force and air defenses
during a four-hour mission u.s
intelligence warns russia could stage an
attack with little warning from belarus
which borders ukraine from the north
tens of thousands woke up without power
in atlantic canada after being battered
by another storm the far-reaching system
brought freezing rain to large parts of
nova scotia leading to downed trees
frozen power lines and treacherous
roadways
parts of new brunswick pei and
newfoundland and labrador were also
affected with some areas seeing as much
as 55 centimeters of snow
that same system caused chaos south of
the border large
blackouts flight cancellations and
traffic disruptions were seen across a
large swath of the u.s jennifer johnson
has the latest
snow sleet and freezing rain turned
roads in the new england states into
sheets of ice and encased cars in rock
hard frozen shells horrible we're
smashing all the ice off right now it's
pretty bad snowfall records were broken
in several regions including parts of
indiana i ain't going to lie i love snow
blowing my wife hates it because i'm
always outside hundreds of thousands
were left without power texas and
tennessee the hardest hit texas power
grid held up much better than it did in
february 2021 when the grid crashed for
several days leaving 200 people dead
still tens of thousands lost power this
time we have no heat and no lights there
it's not a good combination when it's
cold outside the governor is urging
residents to take precautions as this
big freeze sticks around most of the
state will continue to experience
sub-freezing temperatures for a few more
nights the ice was so bad in fort worth
cars slid sideways down this off-ramp a
highway in central texas was shut down
for almost a full day after tractor
trailers jackknifed killing one person
we haven't eaten in 24 hours we haven't
had water
in just about that
same amount of time that highway in
kerrville texas reopened late friday but
roads in several states are still a mess
a lot of spin outs today you know i mean
it's just such a hard thing for
the crews to keep up with and after the
snow and sleet stopped falling the storm
brought in gusty winds and frigid
temperatures
it's pretty cold
my pants are already frozen the
treacherous weather also forced the
cancellation of more than ten thousand
flights thousands of others were delayed
from dallas to boston this monster storm
blocked any clear path for planes to get
in or out
jennifer johnson global news washington
coming up team canada earns its first
two medals of the beijing olympics
canada's first medal of the day belongs
to speed skater isabelle weidemann she
wasn't able to hang on to the top spot
in the 3000 meter finishing with the
bronze this is weinman's second olympic
games she becomes the first canadian
woman on the podium in long track speed
skating since 2010.
quebec's mikhail kingsbury has been
dethroned he hoped his last run would
land him at the top of the podium but it
was not to be trailing behind sweden in
the moguls final after winning the gold
in pyeongchang kingsbury was trying to
win back to back olympic titles
kingsbury is still the most decorated
mogul skier of all time with 71 world
cup victories
it was another blowout for canada's
women's hockey team beating finland 11-1
in just two games canada has scored 23
goals
finland was without its coach for the
game having to fly home suddenly because
of an illness in his family canada will
take on russia next before facing the
u.s early next week to cap round robin
play
still ahead a canadian medical pioneer
the doctor going above and beyond for
organ transplants
come on brag a little send us a picture
of your canada and we'll showcase it at
the end of global national email it to
viewers at globalnational.com
[Applause]
a five-year-old boy was carried out by
rescuers in morocco after being stuck in
a 30-meter deep well since tuesday the
child was rushed away in an ambulance
but state media is now reporting the boy
has died his massive rescue effort
gripped people across the north african
country officials spent days
methodically digging around the well in
order to avoid a collapse or landslide
canada has been a world leader in organ
transplant surgery going back to 1983
when the first successful lung
transplant was performed in toronto
since then one toronto doctor has
devoted his life to lungs this week on
the new reality donna friesen introduces
us to the surgeon who's turning to the
skies in his quest to save more lives
donna
colleen dr khashoggi is one of the
world's top thoracic surgeons and it's
not just because of what he does on the
operating table he has spent his entire
life working on preserving lungs for
transport and this was a first a pair of
human lungs delivered by drone dr
kashabji tells me for him it was like
the kitty hawk and waiting in a hospital
bed was a retired engineer from the
ottawa area el hodak they came to the
room in the afternoon and they said
we've got this project that's
transporting by drones are you
interested in participating they
describe the risk of it
and i said
i'm a technical guy i'm an engineer by
profession
i said advancement of science sure i'll
participate dr khashoggi worked with a
montreal area company unifor
bioelectronics to develop the drone to
ensure the precious cargo would be
protected no matter what happened we
built in a ballistic parachute so with
two
ballistic parachutes right so if the if
the the drone drops too fast tilt
suddenly loses power it will cut all the
engines a parachute will fire and the
drone will come down to the ground
safely and it was very exciting because
like drone guys are like cool engineer
dudes and they can do all that stuff but
they didn't sort of think like it's a
line well i gave a drone crashes i'll
just get another one well no
it's got a lung in it that's a person
that's someone's life dr khashoggi has
made lung transplants his life work and
he's developed techniques to keep organs
alive outside the body preserving them
even tailoring them to the donor and all
his incredible innovations are happening
right here in canada
colleen
donna friesen thank you donna and you
can watch donna's full report tonight at
8 on the new reality right here on
global
next one students effort to reclaim
vancouver's black history
that's the queen kicking off the pomp
and ceremony to mark her platinum
jubilee tomorrow marks queen elizabeth
ii 70th anniversary on the throne the
longest reigning british monarch she
assumed the responsibility in 1952 at
the age of 25 when her father king
george vi died suddenly the queen who is
now 95 was in sparkling form today
laughing and joking with guests
a university of british columbia student
is spearheading an effort to create a
new community hub in an historic
neighborhood maya prashant wants to
establish the vancouver black library
she hopes the facility will reclaim some
of what was lost more than 50 years ago
paul johnson explains
hogan's alley was a very frequently
visited black neighborhood in canada
before the georgia viaduct was built
take a walk with maya preshon around the
neighborhood that once was hogan's alley
she can show you some of the landmarks
like the home on this block where jimi
hendrix's grandmother once lived and
where the guitar god frequently hung out
hogan's alley was really just a vibrant
community neighborhood the same way that
we have commercial drive as little italy
but while the drive chinatown and
vancouver's various other enclaves
mostly aged in place
the city's only black neighborhood was
torn down and dispersed to make way for
the georgia viaduct in 1970 and came
close to being erased from history as
well i am a black person in vancouver
and i was never taught about what
happened with hogan's alley so preshon
came up with an idea
why not create a library to gather all
the materials to tell the story of
hogan's alley and of the black
experience in canada
and also create the kind of community
hub that you see in other big cities
like toronto but not yet in vancouver a
community gathering space it's going to
be a place that people can study a place
where people can chill
preschon and her collaborators initially
set out to raise about six thousand
dollars but when their gofundme campaign
popped to seven grand way faster than
they thought they set their sights
higher
now hoping for 35 thousand dollars
enough to get a lease on a space and
hopefully become a magnet for materials
that go beyond the story of hogan's
alley we have a priority on
books literature
works that are written by black authors
put an emphasis and importance on the
black experience while those original
residents of hogan's alley may have
never expected their community would be
torn down
you also couldn't predict that fifty
years later someone like maya preschoon
would be working to put it back on the
map in a different way paul johnson
global news vancouver
and that is global national for this
saturday night i'm colleen christie
tonight your canada is cultist lake near
chilliwack bc we love to see your corner
of the country so please keep sending
your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching i'll see you back
here tomorrow have a good night
[Music]
you